on duty Chad had sort of a Charlie
rose-ask interview with me about this my
fascination with Hulk Hogan because to
me just he was Superman I was a little
kid and I saw him and that's imprinted
but yeah see this is like asking me who
my favorite child is right so uh The
Rock when The Rock was yeah I mean the
Rocks the rock yeah yeah I mean Hulk
Hogan is
um
he's the weirdest one right for me from
the outside it's super weird that I
don't know what what that is exactly
it's everything's weird about him yeah
he's got the ball head like he would
proudly have this bald head with long
hair the handlebar mustache in this
ketchup and mustard you know tights
which he says he credits McDonald's with
the tights he literally does he says
that the the red and yellow came from
Angelo poffo who's Randy Macho Man
Savage and Lanny poffo's dad who's a
wrestler and and a promoter he said that
he saw him wearing yellow and you know
he's a Tampa guy so he had that brown
skin and the hair and everything so he's
like oh that's what I want to do and
also the brand recognition of like well
I should do it like McDonald's literally
and he's a big you know swollen muscular
uh guy with tanned Brown skins screaming
at me to eat my vitamins and stuff when
I'm eight years old that was extremely
uh yeah he's like Superman I but I know
there's a person behind that guy yeah
you know what do you mean well yeah he's
Terry boleya the dude who you know
does whatever the [ __ ] he does with his
life you know what I mean yeah
complicated life yeah I guess okay to be
him yeah yeah maybe you should change
the the dudes the uh colors to to Yellow
right red and yellow it's currently
orange and um
boy sky blue yeah it's like a nice uh
sky blue